what has two thumbs and just got banned
from Great
Britain this guy John McCrae AKA what do
you meem and I had a perfect plan we
were going to head to Newark for debate
Con on Saturday where I would debate
Robert Spencer on the existence of
Muhammad after the debate we're going to
take an overnight flight to London we
would arrive in London Sunday morning
drop our bags at the hotel and head
straight to Speaker's Corner where our
Muslim friends would have an opportunity
to thank me in person for defending
their profit from the islamophobic
attacks of Robert Spencer we were going
to spend the day at Speaker's Corner
recording the daa guys as they run from
us then we were going to take the
Christians who go to Speakers Corner to
dinner after that we had a three-day
conference The Arc conference Arc stands
for Alliance for respons ible
citizenship Jordan Peterson Ian hery Ali
Douglas Murray Oz Guinness Constantine
kissen Dave Ruben and many many others
were speaking we had a number of
interviews and collaborations lined up
Wednesday evening after the conference
concluded we were going to board the
Eurostar train from London to Paris
because we had a video to record in the
Lou Thursday morning as soon as we were
done recording we were heading back to
the US
from Paris so it was supposed to be one
of the most epic weeks in apologetics
history what could go
wrong Great Britain could go wrong as
it's been doing a lot lately the
organizers of the Ark conference sent us
an email saying that as of January 8th
can't believe they did this on Elvis's
birthday as of January 8th people
traveling to Great Britain from the US
had to apply for an elect ronic travel
authorization an
ETA I've been to Great Britain probably
about a dozen times for conferences and
debates so I didn't think there would be
a problem prior to January 8th if you
wanted to travel from the US to the UK
you bought a plane ticket and brought
your passport but now they require an
ETA so they can weed out any
undesirables I applied for the ETA and
they sent me a rejection message the day
before we were leaving for debate conon
the rejection email said that the
rejection cannot be appealed and that if
I want to travel to the UK I have to
apply for a Visa so I filed an expedited
application for a Visa and they
instantly rejected it dawa clowns of
Speakers Corner Rejoice for David wood
is apparently not allowed to travel to
the UK for any reason ever again now I
don't believe that other countries are
under any obligation to let me into
their country
if they don't want me there I'm not
allowed in Canada if someone says David
you should come to Canada and speak at
our College I tell them I'm not allowed
in Canada but I don't care much the
world is a big place I don't have to go
to Canada I don't have to go to the UK
there are plenty of conferences here in
the US and if something really
interesting is happening in Canada or
the UK I can probably follow it online
so why am I making this video I'm making
this video because instead of the
British government saying don't forget
to get your ETA before you travel as if
it's this simple little step they should
be saying warning do not make plans to
travel here unless you've been granted
an ETA because the government can reject
you without any option to appeal even if
you've been here a million times things
have changed so whatever you do don't
make plans or buy tickets until you've
received an ETA we made our plans before
January 8th so we didn't even know there
was this huge change and that they're
now filtering people out this wouldn't
have been much of a problem if I hadn't
bought plane tickets a conference ticket
Eurostar tickets and Lou tickets all of
them nonrefundable because it never
crossed my mind that I wouldn't be
allowed to travel so thousands of
dollars totally wasted because I had no
clue I was no longer allowed in the UK I
know now but it's been a pretty
expensive lesson fortunately John got to
go and my conference ticket wasn't
wasted tickets to Arc are expensive but
they let me give my ticket to a friend
in London who said he'd love to go but
all the other tickets
wasted so attention British government
please warn people about this so they
don't make the same stupid mistake I
just made and waste a bunch of money
that they really can't afford to waste
the British government of course isn't
going to give people the kind of warning
they should be given which is why I'm
making this video I'm warning you do not
make plans to go to the UK unless you've
jumped through their new Hoops first you
may be thinking but David why would I
want to go to the UK when it's rapidly
turning into to a third world Sharia
compliant hell hole well that's the
reason if you want to visit the UK when
it's still somewhat resembles the UK you
have to do that pretty soon because it's
becoming
unrecognizable so if you ever want to
see the UK you need to do it in the very
near future and if you want to do that
make sure you get the ETA situation
handled before you waste a lot of time
and
money Great Britain Banning me did make
me think about an important difference
between certain Western Nations and
pretty much all other nations at first I
thought about Israel because when AP and
I went to Israel last year they seemed
like they didn't want to let us in when
we were at the airport they asked us
questions for like 45 minutes didn't
seem very
welcoming but the reason they're so
careful is that there are lots of people
who hate them and they don't want to let
people who hate them into their country
when they found out through lots of
questioning that we don't hate them they
let us in that makes
sense but certain Western countries the
UK Germany Sweden France Canada they
want to bring in as many people who hate
them as possible the more you hate them
the more they want you and if you want
to help them if you want their culture
to survive and flourish if you don't
want to see them subjugated you're the
enemy they don't want you there it's
absolutely
insane Eastern European nations places
like Poland and Ukraine really don't
want to be conquered or subjugated they
love their countries if you want to help
them they'll appreciate your help if you
hate them or you want to destroy their
culture they don't want you there why
would they very different from Western
European nations where their leaders are
plagued by guilt over things their
ancestors did and they think that the
only way to attone for the sins of the
past is to hand their cities and wives
and daughters over to people who want to
do really really bad things this makes
me
wonder should we keep trying to help
Nations that despise us for trying to
help
them part of me says yes because no
matter how much you despise me I don't
want jihadis taking your wives and
daughters as captives hate me all you
want I don't want you to submit to that
so I'd still love to help you but we all
have limited time and limited resources
so I'm thinking that maybe the only help
we can give to Western European nations
is to continue warning them hoping that
they eventually break whatever spell
they're under if we're going to help in
other ways maybe we'd be better off
helping countries that want to survive
and who appreciate any help we can give
them for example when we were in Israel
and people found out that we don't want
to see Israel fall to jihadis they had
nothing but love for us from regular
citizens all the way up to government
officials nothing but gratitude towards
people who want to help them lots of
small businesses in Israel went out of
business after the war started because
lots of small small businesses in Israel
are tourism based and there was no
tourism after the war started we
couldn't do much to help businesses but
AP was contacted by someone who said we
could help by promoting artsa boxes
there's a company that gathers products
made in Israel from small businesses
Jewish and Christian businesses and some
Charities and they send them to you in a
box some of the small businesses only
survived because they could sell items
in these Arts of boxes so we each did a
promo which isn't a lot but it's
something we could do and we got a lot
of messages from people who were
extremely grateful that we were even
thinking about helping them again very
different from the UK where if you want
to help them you're the
enemy so there are people who want to
subjugate Western European
nations all we can really do is continue
to War them until they start paying
attention there are people who want to
subjugate other nations and these other
nations don't need to be warned because
they're not insane and they understand
the danger
therein if we can do anything to help
these other nations Nations that
actually want to survive even if we can
only do something small it's good to do
it a bunch of people doing something
small to help adds up to something big
speaking of doing something to help if
you're not signed up to get a quarterly
artsa box please sign up they're not
very expensive especially considering
what you're getting and how many people
you're helping to make it through some
difficult times why is this important
well jihadis are thinking
longterm they often know they can't win
a fight but they'll fight anyway and use
the fight to spread hostility against
their enemy and to hurt the economy of
their enemy with the goal of weakening
their enemy for a future fight they hope
they can win as a general rule when you
figure out what evil people are planning
and you can think of some small way to
toss a monkey wrench into their plan
good idea to do it especially if a bunch
of people start tossing in Monkey
wrenches I just gave you one easy way to
help there's a link to the artsa website
in the description box you can use the
promo code Dizzle for a discount they
won't hate you for signing up they'll
love you for helping they'll love me for
telling you how to
help as for Great Britain or should I
say Not So Great Britain or perhaps even
aspiring Sharia compliant hellhole
britanis stand my goodness warn people
that they might not be welcome in your
country before they make the same stupid
mistake I did that's not a lot to ask
considering the thousands of dollars you
delusional self-destructive clowns just
cost me
[Music]